it's been a brutal week for crypto
investors the value of bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies has plunged the
sell-off began after the collapse of
what was supposed to be one of the
safest crypto assets the so-called
stablecoin tara whose value was pegged
to the u.s dollar
terrorist collapse led investors to dump
bitcoin
which bottomed out at about 26 500 u.s
dollars it was before at about 34 000 us
dollars it has regained some ground on
friday but it still lost more than half
of its value in the last six months that
also goes for the entire crypto market
it was worth about three trillion
dollars in november 2021 it's now worth
about 1.5 trillion dollars
now given that cryptocurrencies are
mostly used for speculation economists
see the global fallout out as limited
with some exceptions take el salvador
the first country to adopt bitcoin as
legal tender have a look
in a market crash regular investors
might panic and run for dear life but
crypto evangelists they just keep cool
and bite the dip
that's what el salvador's president naib
bukele did this week
amid one of the worst crashes in
bitcoin's history he literally bought
the dip spending 15.5 million dollars to
add 500 bitcoins to the national
reserves
in september 2021 in a world first el
salvador adopted bitcoin as legal tender
but after its all-time high in november
the virtual currency's value kept
sliding until this week's disastrous
crash buckeley who describes himself as
the coolest president in the world is in
phase by the crash and has bigger plans
in a display of grandeur he shared
illustrations and models of bitcoin city
a libertarian utopia with no taxes to be
built on the site of the dormant
conchagua volcano
the international monetary fund is
unimpressed in january it pushed el
salvador to ditch its bitcoin experiment
rating agencies fitch and moody have
then downgraded the country's rate to
junk crippling its ability to access
international loans
according to analysts el salvador is now
on the brink of default
now for more on this let's bring in
christy platson from dw business and
bond christy thanks for being here so we
know cryptocurrencies are volatile this
has always been the case why did some
countries like el salvador uh bet so big
on it
right chelsea well there are still a lot
of attractive qualities about
cryptocurrencies um to these markets or
to emerging markets i should say i mean
even with this major dip we're seeing
this week there's still over a trillion
dollars worth of value in that space and
by making uh cryptocurrencies or bitcoin
specifically into legal tender
these these countries like el salvador
are trying to get some of that value
into the country try to get investment
through bitcoin through bitcoin there um
there's also the fact that uh bit uh
cryptocurrency is really quick and free
to transfer so making remittance
payments from abroad back to el salvador
for example is a um a big positive for
them as well so there are several
reasons why they've gotten on board
there well what kind of
economic impact can we expect this to
have the selloff we've seen this week on
their economies
right i mean with this volatility we're
seeing and seeing how invested that el
salvador again for example um is in
bitcoin um there's obviously going to be
a some sort of major impact here as far
as i understand
el salvador has put you know somewhere
over a hundred million dollars into
bitcoin
and now with this recent dip they've
lost somewhere around 40 million uh euro
dollars in bitcoin that is actually more
than the next payment on their uh
foreign bond uh
foreign bond payment coming up in june
and there's some chatter that they might
actually end up having to default on
some of these payments going forward so
this is obviously a major hit and a
major concern for them
so looking just more broadly at the
crypto market obviously we've seen
crypto markets melt down a lot in the
past is this just a temporary blip is it
something more meaningful
uh right well we're in a different
landscape now than we were over the last
years interest rates are rising that we
don't have money flowing um government
money flowing in from the pandemic
anymore so uh cryptocurrencies are going
to have to have a reckoning with the new
financial
environment that they're in now so it'll
be a matter of waiting and seeing but
it's certainly not the same uh type of
crisis we saw in the past
christy platzen and bond thanks so much
for joining us